pictures of a driving protest in
Annapolis Maryland then the center of
the circle there is the Statehouse we're
told hundreds if not thousands of cars
are going to drive around the circle and
protest of Maryland's stay at home order
the governor says it is way too early to
open up in that state this follows a
similar protest in Michigan that took
place earlier this week at least four
sheriffs in that state you can see there
people came out in the driving rain are
saying they are not going to strictly
enforce stay at home orders in their
counties one of those sheriffs kim cole
of mason county joins us now for those
not familiar with michigan geography its
if we put up our hand here it's just
over here on the right side of the coast
there on Lake Michigan good to see you
sir we appreciate it
what of Governor Whitmer's policies and
orders do you find most offensive so I
wouldn't say they're offensive Leland I
would I would say that if I could just
give you a short back history you know
Virginia passed those Second Amendment
issues and laws down there and and what
happened when that took place is people
in Michigan kind of raised an eyebrow
and said boy we hope that doesn't happen
here and then there was some chatter
around Lansing about some gun issues and
all the sudden second amendment
sanctuary County started popping up all
over Michigan and it great it it really
drew a large following and on the heels
of that this kovat matter hit and that
is of course not our governor's fault
it's not anybody's fault it just
happened and the governor issued some
you know some issues there are some
executive orders telling people to stay
home and people are already on edge you
know over the second of nominations and
it creates we heard the president tweet
about the Second Amendment issues as
well when we go through some of the
governor's orders that are more
controversial you're allowed to fish in
a canoe but not from your motorboat for
example is that something that your
sheriff's and water officers would
enforce or not
in our area we would take it on a
case-by-case basis we the governor does
it is an order the governor has that you
can fish from a canoe or a kayak but not
in a 25 horse motored 16 foot deep V
fishing boat we would tends to you is
that is the sheriff you know it really
doesn't to me I mean if I have my boat
at a dock but it's got a motor on it I
can't go a hundred feet out into my pond
and fish but I can get in a canoe in 46
degree water that just potentially tips
over so those are her orders that's it's
it's her right to do that I just I think
there's some room for improvement and we
would hope she would understand you know
your previous guests was speaking out of
Detroit and that it's a beautiful area
down there but we're not Detroit in
northern Michigan a land in the
southeast part of the state you can
drive for miles and never see a tree and
in our area you can drive for miles and
never see a house and it's two different
dynamics as you pointed out before
you're an elected official it's your job
to uphold the Constitution both of the
United States and of the state of
Michigan you enforce the laws as you see
fit the voters can can speak later
this headline caught my attention in the
Washington Post which does not normally
write about Michigan but here it is
almost everybody I know is out of work
how the coronavirus has unleashed
economic havoc in Michigan do you see
that economic havoc number one and
number two are you worried if things
don't get back to normal soon and people
aren't allowed to return to work that
you as sheriff are gonna have some
violations of the law you're gonna have
to enforce yeah so Michigan just passed
the 1 million mark on unemployment
claims this week one of those is my
brother my little brother works
construction and he was laid off because
the site he was at was shut down I don't
take issue with the shutdown the
governor or issued but yeah there's a
lot of people that are hurting in our
area and potential for fire because I'm
a real problem here going for yeah you
know yeah before we went on I was
looking at complaints since the orders
been in place by the governor we've
actually taken 8 criminal complaints
related to the governor's or
we've taken 19 domestic violence calls
Wow and that's high for us in our area
the domestic violence calls vaction
all right well go Sheriff we're gonna
have you back as this goes on because
it's not over and certainly the economic
havoc and catastrophe is not over we
appreciate it sir and I know you're
looking forward to summer up there where
it becomes God's country rather than the
the bleak the bleak the bleakness of the
gray we appreciate it sir all the best
thank you sir
all right thanks Sheriff